If a cryptocurrency like Bitcoin
were to become a commonly accepted
medium of exchange, a global,
decentralized monetary system that
no third party can stop or control,
would the U.S. government attempt to
make it illegal and to prosecute
the developers who contribute to its
code base?
Is software protected by the First
Amendment?
Will the government one day
prosecute individuals who designed
3D printed guns and then make their
plans downloadable on the Internet?
Last week brought cause for alarm
that a federal crackdown on the
decentralized open source software
movement might be coming.
In the past, the US government has
pursued financial service companies
like cryptocurrency exchanges,
holding them criminally liable for
mishandling other people's money
or first facilitating international
payments without following know your
customer and other regulations.
But what happened on August 8th was
different.
The U.S. Treasury Department
announced it was adding tornado
cash, a tool for making
cryptocurrency transactions
anonymous to the U.S.
sanctions list.
Dutch authorities arrested a
suspected developer of tornado cash,
accusing him of facilitating
laundering of billions of dollars
of stolen funds.
What's he guilty of?
Writing code and making it free
on the Internet?
What triggered the U.S.
crackdowns on tornado cash was the
allegation that the Hacking
Collective, the Lazarus Group,
used tornado cash in
an attempt to disguise
cryptocurrency payments worth about
$455 million
to North Korea's missile program.
The Treasury Department's action is
reminiscent of the case against the
software developer Phil Zimmermann,
who developed and distributed
software known as P-Gp
in the early 1990s, which
was the first widely accessible
tool for sending messages over the
Internet with powerful encryption.
I'm delighted to hear good stories
about how it's used in places where
there are oppressive governments.
Zimmerman became the target of a
three year federal investigation on
the grounds that the software was so
powerful that making it possible
for foreigners to download it online
was the equivalent of distributing
weapons to foreign countries without
permission from the State
Department.
The government ultimately dropped
the investigation, thanks in part to
free speech activists who printed
the entire PGB source code in a book
published by MIT Press
and sold it abroad, to make
the point that its creation was
a form of writing protected by
the First Amendment just like any
other book.
Zimmerman's legal battle was part of
what's known as the crypto wars,
which refers to the ongoing battle
to keep powerful cryptography legal.
We just want to make sure we have a
trapdoor and a key under
some judge's authority where
we can get there if somebody
is planning a crime.
Sanctioning of tornado cash
is the latest chapter in that
struggle to better understand its
implications.
I reached out to attorney Jerry
Brito, who's the executive director
of COIN Center, a nonprofit focused
on policy issues and regulations
facing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies.
Briefly, what is tornado
cash and what action did the
U.S. Treasury just take against it?
So
looks like such an easy question.
What's been sanctioned here is not a
person.
There's a sanction on a tool.
And so the sanction really is on
millions of Americans who otherwise
might want to use that tool for
completely lawful purposes
as a result of this sanctioning,
the developers of the tool
have had their accounts suspended at
GitHub, where they publish code.
That in itself is not a violation of
the First Amendment because that's a
private company basically saying,
we don't want you to be publishing
on our platform, but it is
indicia of a chilling effect on
free speech.
So basically, anybody who is
in any way associated with this
tool, which again is a neutral tool
that can be used for good
or for ill, these people are
now being basically
deplatformed in such a way that they
don't have an ability to speak and
may in the future not choose
to speak because of the
repercussions of these sanctions.
Tornado cash is what's known as a
coin mixer, meaning it blends
together multiple cryptocurrency
transactions and then breaks them
out again with the purpose of making
it harder for sleuths to follow the
payment trail.
It's a technique for protecting
financial privacy and has been used
to avoid detection by authoritarian
governments.
Last month I put out a video in
which I asked Alex Gladstein of the
Human Rights Foundation if he was
worried that the government was on
the verge of banning coin mixers
outright.
Is that something you're worried
about, that the very act
of anonymizing your bitcoin will be
deemed by governments to be money
laundering?
What is legally protected as open
source software and free speech is
is coinjoins because they are merely
their open source code.
There's no no one taking control of
your bitcoin.
It's a collaborative spend that's
completely legal here.
And I think if someone tried to make
it illegal, there'd would be very,
very strong, you know, push back
on all kinds of, you know, First
Amendment and Third Amendment,
etc., like all kinds of different
grounds.
So I think that collaborative
spending is going to be defended in
the United States, certainly not in
a dictatorship.
But but here.
Yes.
One reason that Americans
might want to use this tool is to
make anonymous
political speech contributions.
Vitalik Buterin, who is one of
the creators of Ethereum, used
tornado cash to donate funds
to Ukraine.
That's another reason.
You know, there are many political
reasons why you might want to use
tornado cash. That's completely
legitimate.
In the 1990s, the intelligence
community sought congressional
authority to outlaw end to end
encryption on the grounds that
terrorists could use it to
communicate without the NSA
listening in.
Similarly, when adding tornado cash
to the sanctions list, the Treasury
Department asserted that all virtual
currency mixers that assist
criminals are a threat to national
security.
Treasury will continue to
investigate the use of mixers for
illicit purposes.
People who look at the broad strokes
here might say, 'You know what?
North Korea's using this to launder
hundreds of millions of dollars of
stolen money to build weapons that
threaten us.
Something has to be done.' What
do you say to that?
Yeah, you know,
I'm very sympathetic to
the folks in the national
security community
who are seeing this thing that
is a tool is being used
by North Koreans to launder funds
that potentially could then be used
to build weapons of mass destruction,
etc..
And they want to do something about
this.
And unfortunately,
where we are is that the only thing
that seems to be available to them
would be to make it so that nobody
can use it. Right.
Because it really is because it's a
decentralized, unowned
application that anybody can
use. There's really no good way
to be able to allow
law abiding citizens to use it and
disallow bad actors from
using it. Basically, it's a tool
like email, like the Internet too,
that is available for anybody
to use.
And so then really, it comes down to
a question of equities, right?
What do you think is
more important?
Is it a risk of
bad guys using it,
or is it
more important to you that law
abiding citizens have first and
Fourth Amendment rights and privacy
and free speech rights and the
ability to protect them?
Zimmerman says the Treasury
Department's
action is a threat to the entire
cryptocurrency space because it
also made it illegal for any
U.S. citizen to hold cryptocurrency
that previously ran through the
Tornado Cash Mixer.
That's like making it against the
law to possess $100 bill that
at some point passed through the
hands of someone who did something
illegal.
Even if you have no knowledge of its
provenance.
One researcher found that almost
half the addresses in the Ethereum
network are two degrees of
separation away from a tornado cash
transaction.
In other words, they received a
payment from an address that has
received a payment that ran through
the mixer.
What if somebody sends you money
through tornado cash that you never
solicited or know nothing about?
This is the way blockchains work.
And so we've seen that this week.
There's somebody has been doing
that, has been sending small amounts
of cryptocurrency using
tornado cash to prominent
celebrity addresses.
So Jimmy Fallon, for example, was
sent crypto through tornado
cash after the sanctions.
And so now technically, he is in
violation of sanctions law.
What do people like that do?
And then imagine
that you are somebody who receives
through a just normal, law abiding
transaction with somebody who, you
know, is a law abiding person.
You receive funds, but then you
notice that the funds that you
received, maybe four
or five persons back
went through tornado cash.
What is your obligation there, if
any? I would think that would be
none.
But OFAC has not been clear about
what that would be.
They said nothing. It was clear is
not is not the right word if they've
been silent. If this president
stands, there's no reason why
OFAC couldn't say that
signal.
The chat app that's encrypted is
used by North Koreans to facilitate
that activity and it is therefore
banned. Signal is a firm
and so you could put it on a
sanctions list. Now, I kind of take
that back maybe just a little bit
because signal happens to be an
American company and you can't
sanction Americans.
You would have to go through some
due process.
Right.
But you can imagine
that this could happen to some
open source code.
Right. So there is open source code
that if you run it, you can
have a signal like decentralized
encrypted chat.
Well, potentially that could be
added to the list.
And so it's not just cryptocurrency,
right? It's anything that is just
code.
Where do you see
this fight going?
I think what's happening here is
that regulators
and law enforcement have
always relied on intermediaries
to be able to catch bad guys.
Right. So they can always go to
intermediary chokepoints, whether
it's in communications or financial
transactions, and they can go to
those intermediaries.
And using legal process
and regulation, they can
fluctuate their ends.
And with crypto technology, what
they're finding is a lot of the
things that you needed to use an
intermediary for you no longer
do. These things are being
disintermediated.
And so when they go to
try to serve legal process on an
intermediary, they find it, wait
there's no intermediary here.
Right. There's
there's there's a mixing service.
But the mixing service isn't a
service is not a
company.
And so I think this is where they're
taking actions that
are unprecedented and probably
maybe they don't realize it or
probably are straying
into violations of constitutional
rights.
And so that's just something we're
going to have to go through.
At the end of the day, I'm
optimistic because our Constitution
has served us well for 250 years.
I think it will continue to do so,
and I think we will find the right
balance. Unfortunately, I think it's
going to have to go through the
courts.
Tornado cash is a tool
and tools are neutral, just
like Bitcoin encryption, guns,
even telephones.
Terrorists and dictators can use
them, as can human rights activists
and dissidents.
The government should target the
criminals and authoritarians who
threaten human freedom, not
the programmers and cryptographers
who build new technologies that
can better secure human freedom.